nouveau numéro de reporter sur france 24
c'est un carnet de route exceptionnelle
que nous vous proposons aujourd'hui sur
les routes de l'exode en ukraine en ce
mois de mars 2022 alors que le pays fait
face au plus grand exode depuis la
seconde guerre mondiale une équipe de
france 24 traverse l'ukraine par l'ouest
pour parvenir à rejoindre kiev la
capitale dont on attend le siège
imminent pendant une semaine nos envoyés
spéciaux vont partager la vie des
réfugiés des volontaires et des soldats
d'ukrainiens sur le front dire pin ville
résidentielle du nord ouest cible de
l'offensive russe sur kiev avec artem le
combattant d'origine kozak ou sergei le
déserteur de la légion étrangère qui a
traversé la france avec sa voiture pour
défendre son pays natal où avec encore
dans inquiète fantomatique l'artiste
bodan moucha descendants de l'inventeur
de l'art nouveau qui a décidé de rester
et de résister la bataille dire pin
carnet de route en ukraine reportage de
cyril payen georgie asbeck avec gabriel
viala et victoria nukem enhco
[Musique]
l'instrument
ce
mon
mensonge
[Musique]
if i'm looking
tête
[Musique]
j'ai
des chenaux semaine
[Musique]
tu as des nouvelles de chez toi en
russie que pense-t-il là bas de la
situation
on ne me croit pas c'est complètement
dingue à moscou mes amis me disent même
combien on te paie pour dire de tels
mensonges c'est comme si je les
suppliais pour demander de l'aide et
qu'il me réponde arrêté blague
je le sais maintenant si j'ai à le faire
je n'hésiterai pas je prendrai les armes
c'est ici chez moi je protègerai ma
maison mes amis et toi
et ton petit frère que devient-il tu
sais quelque chose non rien je sais
simplement qu'il était sous contrat dans
l'armée dans ma ville en russie d'après
quelques informations que j'ai pu
obtenir au pays son unité est parti au
front dès le début de l'offensive en
ukraine
je n'ai aucun contact avec lui je sais
qu'il est quelque part là en face
tous les ukrainiens qui sont réfugiés en
france à l'étranger ne vous inquiétez
pas nous allons gagner et vous pourrez
bientôt tous rentrés chez eux de mieux
si vous voulez vous pouvez rentrer cette
côte et ses côtés des
armées qui contrôlent
[Applaudissements]
tiens je te file saporta grenade c'est
bon ça va marcher oui c'est bon bonne
chance merci
allez on va flinguer ces [__] de
russes
on a déjà tué des russes tous les jours
combien ça fait quatorze jours que je
suis là
j'habite ici je suis d'ici là
bon maintenant c'est chaud attention ils
sont dans le parc juste dans la rue la
halle
ici c'est chaud très dangereuse
lie à leur checkpoint
na 200 m lui aussi qui voit les tanks un
nom
à ton petit peu à temps c'est pas une
bonne idée il faut y aller l'unc
[Musique]
moqueurs qui l'a tué
des soldats russes
kalba les russes ont commencé à attaquer
de l'autre côté du parc lalla par le sud
il y avait plein de gens
les civils et au sommet ils ont fait
exprès de tirer sur les signale que le
roi à l'eag one ils tuent tout le monde
progresse en ce qui me l'ont dit
on en faire
allez viens suis-moi
ça c'est de l'alcool tu vois et en
ukraine maintenant c'est interdit
unité sur montre
[__]
chef
ça va bien pour nous
nous ne sommes pas caché
il n'y a pas de point de retour on ne
lâchera rien fait notre pays
tous ces [__] d'envahisseurs russie
ils vont regretter d'être venu on va
faire de l'engrais avec leurs cadavres
[Musique]
de la nourriture nous ne manquons pas
pour l'instant le problème c'est
l'électricité et l'eau bien sûr
donc tout dépend de la suite
mais les russes ne sont pas loin oui
mais vous pensez que vous allez devoir
partir aussi vous avez un plan
non aux plaines aucun plan
regardez nous avons des gens ici et ils
ont besoin de nous
mon pauvre chien est à la rue comme moi
je suis à la rue ils ont bombardé la
maison on cherche un adoré nous sommes
en vie
mais je n'ai rien à manger pour lui mon
pauvre chien eu
comme un groupe de seize soldats russes
est arrivé
c'était des jeunes recrues de bouriatte
yeux
les gens ont demandé qu'est ce que
l'ukraine a fait à bord et à thiais
pourquoi nous envahissent et vous
pourquoi venez-vous nous massacrer nous
l'ukrainien il ne répondrait un rien
juste il aurait pété nous avons des
ordres nous devons obéir aux ordres
il ya des cadavres partout en passant
nous avons même dû cacher les yeux des
enfants pour qu'ils ne regardent pas que
des civils c'est effroyable
on vient de passer devant vingt cadavres
juste là dans la rue là bas
il y avait un mort tout près du pont
c'est pas possible
de pauvres gens qui étaient à vélo et
qu'ils tentaient de fuir c'est vrai j'ai
pas du choc
merci merci d'être là pour nous défendre
nous prions pour vous libérez nous des
envahisseurs
merci on va les envoyer en enfer mon
cher fils je prierai pour toi tous les
soirs tenez bon nouveau chéri sont comme
nos enfants
merci merci beaucoup que dieu vous garde
en vie et que vous soyez réunis avec vos
familles vous êtes le héros
merci
ne vous en faites pas nous vaincrons
nous allons gagner
merci merci
pas nécessaire c'est marrant non ça nous
sommes en guerre et quelqu'un m'a collé
une pub sur le pare-brise sadi étudiants
étrangers comment trouver un boulot à
kiev legault
c'est la statue du grand résistant board
and kill on its qui ça fait deux bords
dan
[Musique]
qui êtes-vous avec un français
gloire à l'ukraine gloire aux héros
cette place où vous posez les pieds
aujourd'hui très importante c'est un
endroit sacré pour nous peuple slave
nous avons été au cours des temps appelé
rousse puis rutten
mais maintenant nous sommes ukrainien à
chasseneuil où
nous sommes l'ukrainien depuis à peine
plus d'une centaine d'années
j'étudie notre religion notre foi cette
fois est extrêmement puissante est
centrale pour nous depuis la nuit des
temps et la conclusion est la suivante
si nous sommes d'ukrainiens c'est que
nous avons résisté l'ukraine signifie
résistance
[Musique]
au fond
sa barque ouais ça va ça va je suis prêt
je suis prêt pour la bagarre laisse
aller ça va péter
mais ils sont très proches dont
way ces connards sont en train de
pilonner ils essaient de flinguer notre
artillerie
on va leur répondre on va aller réduire
ensemble
il veut dire oui savoir un homme qui en
cas
[Musique]
de baisse ils ont défoncé le croyez quoi
comment
ping
alors
[Musique]
et voilà pour ce carnet de route en
ukraine reportage signé cyril payen
georgia ce bec avec gabriel viala et
victoria yuki mccaw c'est la fin de ce
magazine vous retrouvez nos équipes sur
le terrain tous les jours en direct sur
nos antennes et nous on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
de reporter sur france 24
[Musique]